ah that was awesome
it's awesome hey what is goodbye
I'm okay and joking yes but this is Ken
Oshiro skin right right how did you come
from
I've never baked here the whole time how
long have you guys are playing games now
me
are you wear pajamas get in here get in
the middle is about you MA
yeah my friendís um I'm the bomber man
oh yeah man I know what do you okay
there's a CPU with us okay I'm the red
one I'm the one with a skirt that is the
most prettiest oh look I'm gonna die one
where were you guys all right don't
worry about it I'm hiding in the
darkness okay I know where oh yeah lets
me down yeah oh you won't be so slow
where you're down he passed you tell me
that as much as that is this year I
don't know I don't know do you know what
oh my god I'm gay I'm gay I'm gay how
you use the mines oh that's how oh I can
shoot you oh okay now it's you versus
the compose oh it's a beauty I'm so cute
Jacob ah I wrote down killer selfies
media all right come on oh you going to
dab eight you save that one before yeah
we're lucky there come on
what's up blue anyway but what's blue we
kill the blue one and helped me out you
got a blue
oh sorry darkness I burn my throat how's
this EP with good good job the CTO [ __ ]
gems yeah yeah yeah yeah give it a hit
okay
I still on a who the hell are you
getting I'm Polaris gaming oh that's
very helpful thank you so much happy you
guys know that I'm the one don't tell me
I'm not you yes one day I gave anybody
gonna die everybody in this helped speed
downs there's no Hollins I don't care
nobody came Oh what are you doing I
don't know trying to murder something
blew up half the whole world half the
whole Oh God how did that man my god
fine I'm gonna talents abused Oh why
would you do that Daddy
oh I'm telling me whatever I'm sorry
please don't murder me from the grave
haha
dopey dopey hey last winner that's me
come on yay you got hit in the face no
one in facial no I want when I still
don't know where ever anything yeah fun
alright you Vic alright redness this
time you got
oh my god there's a Bob disappeared just
through its open the side I don't do
that oh we don't make up sub I didn't do
I've never seen that happen when you
play I'm mad no I just why I dissect I
killed you just from the grave noted are
you white right what happened me crazy
whatever doesn't matter it's all about
having fun
oh that's right castle know it bombs
have to do this my life my family thank
you there you go random crowd avenging I
am plasma gaming I'm wrong you hog all
the points victory get you okay no no no
kill rags whatever what having fun are
you guys have not ever you are you
having ham bone Beckham I live fun so
much fun starts singing no you're going
to tell is that I don't have it
wait I haven't wait dude I don't I
almost just killed you again hey hey
back Punk but I back to Haga thank you
for me you want a present I give you aa
computer kill dem cities oh oh I'm sorry
haha what second oh don't kill me oh I
thought the skull was a ghost of walls
ah
hey come let's go on all the wake up
computers my business okay
finish your sentence oh you're going
down everyone down one day or intrepid
abuse oh what'd I do
that explodes huh it's just time the
tiny explosion oh no you click it to
exploit it looks like a painting and it
is a pancake look what what happened
what happened there
what's it what I do not push your
buttons I'm trying figure how to do it -
ok motion sickness and don't be a tell
you both the pancakes but what's your
neck you know all of them hurry up hurry
up Toby oh I can you show the power of
Grayskull there's no grace Oh goodbye
bomber down good everyone yeah pops
bread
little pancakes oh my laundry don't talk
about don't explode the pancakes
pancakes just want to be I'm scared the
or night ends don't want to hang I don't
know oh I got with the dress wins okay
we're just like in real life always with
a number three how can we how can the
CPU
you it's not him he's Peter good he's
you know did we mail you man you know he
hasn't talked any smack the whole game
well who's jerking who's jerking it sit
screen it's not me do you not you know
wait wait what's happening
I think it's pushing on the on the right
guys told me it was you all along I love
you all alone got that this game all
right chuckles you going down
no one's going you going down going down
tell me you are literally in an elevator
and it's going down wait is that what it
uh you were just literally going down as
a batch of skills or anything okay if I
put in half there's no house today
no elevator no no boo God who is sitting
blue one second can I help you like dad
Toby's like yeah pancakes Oh where's
game hello everyone what was that one
second a frame wait wait wait
yo Kelly wait you said Shh okay so
you're the background hey Zack what's on
the black mutro city yeah what are you
trying to do you think he's that open
about that I mean obviously and you're
from Mississippi no look I'm from
Mississippi - you really are I think you
two are brothers I got out of I know you
said we probably are separated like 80
cousins 30 I have many more in my legs
God seriously right now what's your
mom's names uh my mom's names well she's
all Jackie - Toby Joe though that's kind
of make the most important that's good
my middle name is Joe thank you for
telling I'm Mississippi well you're
welcome
I have a pancake does anyone want to
open it we sent a whole order pancake oh
oh oh I guess you gonna eat your damn
game in my back you so you sent there so
gently an offer pancake
I don't want to give you guys wind of a
customer you know
coming up me are you gonna take it a
block oh you love the phone it'll sting
what's the P do tango Pete what's the
hot damn phone
haha the PA Oh pumpkin oh oh learning
can ELISA oh I did something bad oh nice
you just kind of murdered me oh well
Hearst one again nice dance I do it Oh
am i waiting on Tim getting on and
winning cuz I'm so good at this total
one
alright Blair hey wait where the wings
okay now you go what what I was just
fooling here you can say so why don't
win this one has wins everything is
everything okay in the room there's some
cool stuff yes
okay no you okay um is it you're given
you know what this pillow you want that
for the it's getting you're not getting
it when I sit down the coffee table has
a display of potential future winnings
okay at all times who see that another
rep revision did you see yeah I'm crying
I win this one
sorry gotta get going I want that pillow
add on redness Ralph skirts skirts
tulips cooing pills
that's my skirt skirt Appeals oh you
could've girls get nothing I think I
lost oh I won that hello bacon that is
my color oops no don't don't do that
don't lose me Tommy to the great Tommy
don't never Bob such a thousand don't
ever ups the pills ready how can you oh
stop
I don't your life don't your life is
running out time it's a big no no no
Nanette the big life clock
everyone has a clock fast Tommy throw
out the black ball it's not racist just
do it yeah it's not because Mon stop
whoa hold on you will sit on it I'm
Jenny from her blog yeah okay get that
book trust Oh hurry on Tommy get him I
think my kid I got on the side I'll be
as we're doing the hurry up hurry up now
you're gonna be slower though oh whoa oh
my good mind
oh my god that's my hey you money let's
go I just for the full count that's what
your plan all along
thank you guys it's been a lot of fun
I've enjoyed sharing this moment get on
there get in there you little you little
cuddle bunny from foreign countries now
a gymnast you would be doing videos
weirder than it you could have ever
imagined a missus obscure subscribe for
more of this of that all you can handle
I vomited that was awesome Snapple oh
man
pillow God dang it